Today, we'll be turning things upside down and apply what we learned so far about estimation
and probability to solve some really basic statistical problems that occur everyday.
Today, we talk about confidence intervals and in the next class we talk about testing hypothesis.
These are fundamental concepts that every applied statistician has to used pretty much everyday.
You'd better listen. This is my first example.
Imagine it is just about election day, and I know not all countries have election days
but I wish they did and I wish they were fair.
In the United States, they have 700 million people that are eligible to vote
over those a section go and vote, but as a transition
you often wish to understand what the outcome of election day is before the actual vote happens.
One thing you could is to ask every voter and then just report the results. Is this a good idea?